I have been running rife programs lately to help you with allergies and even briefly to help with a
lost steam. This may be curious, especially in relationship to the allergies. Is the rife
just managing the symptoms or is it helping to underlie disease disease or imbalance? In other words,
will the rife just manage symptoms or will it fix what's wrong? Good question. So what's the mechanism
of action for the rife frequencies and what frequencies you're running? So I've long said the
mechanism action that I believe the rife does for cancer as it stimulates the cancer cell so that
the immune system will take another look at it and create more T cells and natural killer cells to
kill the cancer. However, cancer is your own cell, so normally your immune system shouldn't
attack your own cells. So when you hit it with the rife, you're causing it to vibrate, you're
causing it to look differently than other cells, you're causing your immune system to see it as an
enemy into attack it. Well, how does that work with other things? When you're running the rife for
your liver function, let's say, how is that work? Are you killing the liver? Well, no. When you're
running the rife at the liver frequencies, you're trying to bring back the natural frequency
of the, so when the liver isn't functioning correctly or what a tissue isn't functioning correctly,
it may be a different frequency. So if you could get it to vibrate back at a normal frequency,
you could bring back normal tissue residents and you could help that tissue heal. Well, how's it
working with allergies? What's the mechanism of action with allergies? Well, the mechanism of
action with allergies is you're trying to stimulate a T-reg function. So there's different T cells
in your body. There's natural killer cells. There's T cells that are helping kill cancer. There's
macrophages. There's dendritic cells that then will form into other cells. And then there's what
are called T-reg cells. So as far as gross understanding of the immune system, you have a T-H-1
response or an immediate immune response that kills pathogens. You have a T-H-2 response for a
B cell response that makes antibiotics. So the purpose of an immune response to, let's say, a pathogen
is that you fire this immediate cell response to be able to kill that pathogen. That's what's
taking place in an allergic reaction or a hyperhistamine reaction. You're getting this hyper T-H-1
cytokines. cytokines are different chemicals in an immune response. You're getting this hyper T-H-1
cytokine response. So it's spilling out these inflammatory cytokines to stimulate an immune
attack on whatever's there. The problem is whatever is there isn't a living organism, let's say in the
case of pollen, then there's nothing to kill, and you could end up getting this hyper histamine
response. You couple that with a person having defects in their H-N-M-T gene, which are the genes that
make the DAO enzyme, which breaks down histamine in the tissue. So you don't get a lot of tissue
breakdown of histamine. You could end up with excessive histamine response in the tissue,
aka allergies. So a person who has allergies, stipples, colds, allergic response in the skin,
itchy skin, all this because of, let's say, an environmental allergen, let's say, a
pollen response, that's the whole cycle that's taking place. You also have, so you have, that's the T-H-1
response that's taking place. You don't even want to fire a T-H-2 response, because a T-H-2
response would be responsible for making antibody. So in a normal, healthy immune response, let's say
you get a bacterial infection. Your child comes home from school with strep. You pick up the strep
fire, the strep bacteria. Now it starts activated your body and replicated your body. It stimulates a
T-H-1 response. You fire the cytokine response to attract T-cells, macrophages, natural killer cells
to that site. You get this antigen pairing response. It ties to the antigen, the bacteria, and those T-cells
kill that bacteria. Now, let's say it's a really, really bad bacteria, and you get really sick,
and you don't feel good. You get a fever. The fever is this hyperinflammatory response,
and you have to take off the next day at work, and the T-H-1 response is not stealthful enough to kill
that bacteria. Then it now suppresses, and you stimulate the T-H-2 side of the immune system,
the B-cells. The B-cells go in, find that which you are firing, and T-H-1 response against,
in this case, the strep, and you now make antibodies against strep. That's a good thing.
That's a good thing. That's why you don't want to, oh, I don't feel good. I have a fever.
I'm going to take Tylenol. I'm going to take just a drug all the time when you have a bacterial
infection. Sometimes it's good for it to go its course, so you fire a T-H-1 response, T-H-2 response,
because that's how you build your immune system. When you have that T-H-2 response,
you could now create antibodies against strep. Next time when you get strep, when your child comes
home six months from now, if the school brings home strep, you don't get sick. Why? Because you have a
stronger immune system. How is that defined? You define a stronger immune system by that which you
have encirculated antibodies against. I have circulated antibodies against strep. I have circulated
antibodies against this step that I want to take. The more things you have circulated antibodies
against, that is pathogens, you have circulated antibodies against. The stronger your immune system is
going to be a K-A, meaning that every time you're exposed to that, or a very similar pathogen,
that antibody tags it. Even a mild T-H-1 response that doesn't elicit a fever will kill it quite
easily because it's easy to find. Think of that antibody as fluorescent tape that it goes and
tags that pathogen. To much information, well, there's another piece. There's what's called your T-reg
cells, your T regulatory cells. Those T-reg cells help balance this. You don't get this hyper-T-H-1
response, or this hyper-T-H-2 response that could create antibodies to things that you don't want to
write, self-tissue, and then causing an autoimmune disease. T-reg cells are important. That's what I
think the allergy frequencies in the RIF are doing is stimulating a T-reg response. What are some
nutritional things that help stimulate T-reg responses with allergies? Vitamin D is a wonderful T-regulator
substance. Bitticidal mushrooms are great T-reg stimulator substance. That's why a lot of
so much is you could use medicinal mushrooms to help kill pathogens in people that have an autoimmune
disease, because it's not going to be a hyper-T-H-1 response. They're like vitamin C well, but it's going
to help stimulate T-reg cells. Also, understand that immune response. If you have allergies, you shouldn't
be using things that will directly stimulate a T-H-1 response, like vitamin C, and things like that,
that will be like echinacea. A lot of people are taking those things for their cancer, but if you're
experiencing hyper allergic responses to things that's good to back off on those for a period of time,
so it calms that T-H-1 response down so it can help get rid of those cytokines. When you talk about,
okay, I talked about allergies as far as environmental allergies, but the exact same thing is taking
place when you get a B-Stig or a WASP-Stig, so that's the same thing taking place.